cuál de las siguientes funciones tiene
un mínimo local con valor 1 así que
pensemos un segundo en esto aquí nos dan
la tablita con las funciones y notemos
que los valores de x van aumentando
desde menos 4 hasta 4 así que mis x van
creciendo conforme bajó en la tabla y
bien nos piden encontrar qué función
tiene un mínimo local con valor 1 es
decir que la función en el 1 toma su
valor más chico cerca de ese punto así
que veamos donde alcanza fx al valor 1
pues lo alcanza aquí cuando x vale menos
1 f x vale 1 que hay deje de x pues gdx
pasa por el 1 justo acá y hdx lo hace
por aquí así que bien
analicemos qué sucede con fx cuando x
vale menos 2 efe de menos 20 cuando x
vale menos 1 fx vale 1 y cuando x vale 0
fx vale 5 así que parece que no va a ser
un mínimo porque está creciendo es más
déjenme hago una gráfica por acá
para que veamos lo que está pasando
eje x
jeje
1 2 3 4 5
45 bien entonces la función alcanza el
valor 1 en menos 1 efe al menos entonces
cuando estoy aquí en menos 1 que sería
este valor de aquí la función vale 1
cuando estoy en -2 la función vale cero
y cuando estoy en cero la función vale 5
así que se asumo que estas son muestras
tomadas de una función continua la
función se vería algo así por lo tanto
uno no es un mínimo local estoy
creciendo paso cada vez a valer más por
lo tanto no es un mínimo local que hay
deje de x pues
gx alcanza el valor 1 cuando x vale 2
así que cuando x vale 2 estoy aquí en 1
esto es el 2
y cuánto vale la función en uno pues en
uno la función vale 2
2 más o menos por aquí y en 3 la función
vale menos 1 en 3 la función vale menos
y esto es menos 1 entonces ahora está
sucediendo
el fenómeno inverso ahora parece que la
función está decreciendo pero nuevamente
el 1 no es un mínimo si la función
tuviera un mínimo que valiera 1 la
función tendría que decrecer al
acercarse por la izquierda para luego
crecer al alejarse por la derecha por
así decirlo entonces
fx no fue eje x tampoco fue que hay de
hd x pues hdx
hdx
lo voy a hacer en rojo hdx vale 1 en
menos 3 así que aquí en menos 3
hdx vale 1
y en -4 que sería este punto de acá en
-4 la función vale 5
y en -2 la función vale 3
así que si extrapoló esto digamos la
función quizás se vería algo así y
entonces este es justo el fenómeno que
queremos mientras me acerco de la
izquierda la función decrece hasta
alcanzar el 1 donde toma su valor mínimo
para después comenzar a crecer de nuevo
así que la función que tiene un mínimo
local con valor 1 es hd x